there are two things I support in the
world folks entertaining horror movies
and education it's actually a flux mean
saying this video is brought to you by
Full Sail University more on that in a
second but for now let's review the
scary Annabelle creation - Annabelle
creation takes place before the first
shitty Annabelle movie takes place in
this house for this guy and his wife
have decided to take on these orphans
but there's an assorted past in this
house and when one of the kids finds
that creepy-ass Annabelle doll all bets
are off now we have ourselves a horror
movie which yeah right out the gate you
hear that premise you're like I feel
like I've seen this horror movie before
generally speaking you have I could
probably say in terms of horror movies
like this like the haunting demon horror
movies no matter what anyone does with
that premise you have Xena before how
many times can they have that creepy
doll causing problems I have no idea at
least one more for this movie first I've
got to warn you about the trailer don't
watch the trailer the trailer ruins the
movie just it tells you way too much
most of the stuff you see in the trailer
takes place in the second half of the
movie yeah the second half when the
questions are being asked questions are
being entered plot points are revealed
things you want to save for the movie so
don't do that but the movie really was
effective it used good creepy ass
imagery to get its point across with
shadows and creepy demon ghosts things
that wocka [ __ ] up it was actually
really cool a couple times it totally
projects it your luck is this is going
to happen now isn't it again like I said
you've seen this before and then it does
happen sometimes you're like this is
going to Ono it didn't in another way
Wow little tricked me the movie uses a
couple of jump scares but doesn't over
use jump scares the second half of the
movie is way more interesting than the
first half the first half being set up
the set up just kind of a little boring
it really made me see why horror movies
use jump scares in a world where you're
trying to build up these characters and
those horror movies don't have
interesting characters like to do I
don't know it's going to get boring
let's just use jump scares it's really
doing a fine job at building up a couple
of their characters some of the other
ones couldn't even tell you I can't tell
you how many girls were actually staying
in this house couple women they just
fade into the background and in a world
of scary haunting horror movie cliches
they're all idiots a few of the girls
they make them like why are you doing
that you could pass it off as well this
is probably the first haunting any of
them have heard about it takes place a
while ago like they're all amazing
there's a TV in the house it's like that
alright I get it however without
spoiling it there's a scene where
someone dies and that
person is straight-up like blue and
veiny they've died under mysterious
circumstances and they look unnaturally
dead then someone's like oh look at the
time alright kids it's bedtime let's get
the bed what's up [ __ ] are you talking
about Lee why are you staying there
denies there was a blue weird dead veiny
person on the ground was that going to
go if you can't see that kind of red
flag from a mile away maybe you guys
deserve to die the guys in the end I
actually enjoyed Annabelle creation
which is baffling to me because the
first end of all no it's not ground
right here anything but I applaud their
use of effective horror element in here
you don't have to jump scare every five
seconds leave a beat leave a breath let
the audience marinate in its own anxiety
it actually attempts to do that on quite
a few occasions more or less succeed the
acting was solid and I can actually say
alright we have ourselves a conjuring
prequel finally for the first time ever
in life in the end I will say Annabelle
creation was a good time to alcohol
required and please just skip the
trailers just saying my trailers gotta
ruin [ __ ] and again this video is
brought to you by Full Sail University
Full Sail University is the education
destination for my fellow film industry
enthusiasts but Full Sail you get the
opportunity to take your film experience
to the next level with programs in film
or online digital cinematography degree
program these courses offer you the
student the opportunity to work on a
film from start to finish
so while learning about it you don't
just hear about it you do it you learn
about each member's role in production
as a filmmaking student you learn about
artistic concepts and technical tools
from every angle this includes
documentary commercial production and
web video if you're interested in
advancing your degree at Full Sail
University go to Full Sail dot edu slash
Jeremy John's or do it the easy way and
click that link in the description go
out there folks
make me proud maybe one day I can review
your movie alright guys so Annabelle
creation have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's a surprisingly
enjoyable horror movie for you whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]